んん～！？
んッんｯﾊﾟﾝｯ
ﾊﾟﾝｯｽｰ
くさｱー！
皆さん夏といえばもちろん
まあ海とかプールに行くと誰しもがこのスイカのビーチボールで遊んでると思うんですけども
ﾊﾟﾝｯバンッ
このビーチボールを使ってとある実験をしようと思います
とりあえずたくさん作ります
スイカにもやしパワーを吹き込みます
もやしパワー枯渇
はいというわけでたくさんのスイカのビーチボールを準備しました
今回ですね前はね普通に使ってたんですけど
破けちゃって壊れちゃったんですよ
そこでだ
そこでこの壊れたスイカのビーチボールに小細工をしていこうと思う
はじゃみ
よしこういう感じであきましたと
でこの中に
入るかな
やべえやべえさすがに違和感しかねえな
さすがにこれだと違和感しかないですね
被せます
あっえっすごい待って
あとはなるべく締め上げてシワをなくせば結構バレない気がするんですよね
ガムテープの音
いやパッと見大丈夫なんじゃねえかなこれ
はいというわけでパッと見全部普通スイカのビーチボールに見えるんですけども
で多分なんですけどちょっとシワが目立つんですけど
これをこう並べて
外に置いといて
俺が蹴って蹴ってって言って
１個ずつ蹴っていくと
蹴って蹴って蹴ってラスト一個蹴ったー
本物のスイカだったっていう
なんか自分が割るというか誰かに割ってもらったスイカを食べたいので
ｴﾍｯえーターゲットに足でスイカ割りをしてもらおうと思います
ﾌｯﾌｩｯどんな顔するのかなー
というわけでスイカのビーチボールを蹴ったら本物のスイカだったドッキリやっていこうと思います
ではいこう
ﾋﾟｭﾋﾟｭ
やべえなくなってるなくなってる
ピィー
PKたいけーつ
1発ずつ全部俺に本気で蹴ってきて
ﾊﾟｧｧｧｯﾝ×５
痛てぇー！
ﾊｯﾊｯｯｯﾊｧﾊｱｧｧｯ
あっえっ待って
クパァ///
というわけでビーチボールのスイカと思ったら本物のスイカドッキリでした
うめぇな